we're going to begin with that whether
cities across the Midwest are scrambling
to protect people from this deadly polar
vortex that is blasting the region with
what is called the coldest air in
decades at least six deaths across the
u.s. are connected to this winter storm
and tens of millions of Americans are at
risk this morning cities like Fargo
North Dakota Madison Wisconsin and
Chicago will experience highs far below
zero today in many places schools and
offices are closed the US Postal Service
canceled deliveries today in all or
parts of at least ten states DeMarco
Morgan is in Minneapolis where the city
is preparing for historic cold tomorrow
good morning good morning to you is if
you need any more proof as to just how
cold it is take a look at the Minnehaha
Falls right here behind me you can see
it is completely frozen right here and
it is just an example of how cold it is
across this region that's why safety is
now a major concern the combination of
snow and below average temperatures is
making everyday tasks almost unbearable
I have seven layers on and Fargo North
Dakota emergency responders braved
temperatures hovering around 20 below
zero to assist victims in a car crash in
Grand Rapids Michigan whiteout
conditions are being blamed for a chain
reaction of crashes involving at least
two two dozen vehicles no one was killed
the arctic blast also put a stop to
public transportation Amtrak cancelled
all of its trains at Chicago's Union
Station due to the extreme cold in
Minneapolis police hit the streets to
help those in need they handed out free
gloves to kids and low-income
neighborhoods it's important just to
connect with the community and make sure
people are safe in this weather later in
the evening officers took us through the
city looking for homeless people to help
the reality of it is is too dangerous
for people to be out here in the street
we encountered a man sleeping outside in
20-below weather he eventually allowed
officers to call an ambulance for got
him out picked him up got him
[Music]
dr. got to be honest with you that was
heartbreaking and very touching just to
watch that situation there sergeant
Snyder said sunny was shown in the
beginning signs of frostbite - it was
crucial to get him off the streets and
again we can't say it enough before it's
all said and done the windchill here
will feel like it's 50 to 60 degrees
below so if you I can stay inside please
do so it's important nor a good warning
DeMarco how many layers do you have on
oh I have an about 10 to 12 layers on
more it is freezing out here and we also
have a heated tent you probably can't
see it but it's ah it's to my left there
you go it's out here then this is for
mrs. Morgan who still checks on our baby
boy who's grown to make sure that he's
staying warm we do have a heated tent so
our crew is safe out here just in case
somebody's watching and saying look you
know why are they outside we're here
just to keep people safe that's how we
do our job stay safe out there and Thank
You DeMarco